the fugitive grandmother accused of
murder in two states is in custody this
morning Louis Reese is suspected of
killing her husband in Minnesota and a
woman in Florida then allegedly stealing
the woman's identity Reese was arrested
last night on on South Padre Island in
Texas vladimir duthiers shows us how the
four week nationwide search ended Vlad
good morning good morning
the US Marshals say Risa furs from
gambling addiction she's believed to be
in debt and accused of stealing at least
eleven thousand dollars from her
husband's bank account law enforcement
officials even gave her a nickname
losing streak Louis but after a month on
the run her luck finally ran out newly
released surveillance video shows Louis
Reese at an Iowa gas station the same
day her husband David was found shot to
death in their Minnesota home she buys a
sandwich then asked the cashier for
directions on April 5th Reese popped up
roughly 1,300 miles away in Fort Myers
Beach Florida there she was seen
chatting with Pamela Hutchinson who
police say Reese killed four days later
Miss Hutchinson was targeted by the
suspect due to the similarities and
their appearance
police say Reese used Hutchinson's
identification and was spotted at a
Florida hotel driving her white Acura
and wearing what her family says was her
white fedora
investigators say Reese then drove about
1,300 miles along the Gulf Coast with
sightings in Louisiana and Texas until
she was arrested Thursday on South Padre
Island 27 miles from the Mexico border
Pamela Hutchinson's cousin Ellen was
overwhelmed with the news of Reese's
capture Murray spent Thursday night at a
jail on South Padre Island local
authorities say law enforcement from
Minnesota and Florida are headed to
Texas to coordinate the next steps in
the investigation Gail glad she's in
custody thank you very much glad